wir haben uns heute hier mal wieder
zahlreich versammelt bei der damen und
herren um auf eine neue episode toto
händel zu reagieren
in der situation hätte ich auch von der
torte genannt
ach es geht noch um roller und schon am
ende meiner letzten action oft orte
hände vor einigen tagen war es ja so
dass die uhr bei honda und schon mal
grün aufgeleuchtet hat lässt sie durften
sich küssen haben sie auch gemacht und
dann haben sie auch die nacht
miteinander verbracht alle sind neidisch
auf hashtag scharon war es ja nicht dass
sie die ganze nacht in münchen gehalten
haben ich glaube auch nicht
übrigens preis meine lieben freunde es
ein neues mitglied auf der insel sind
für mich jetzt hätte ich im lotto
gewonnen
ihre frage ist habt ihr super gespielt
[Musik]
das war
der mit abstand schlechteste wortwitz
den ich je gehört habe
unfassbar ich hätte die prinzen geglückt
ich hoffe nicht
die meinungen sind ein bisschen getrennt
aber ich glaube es ist doch immer
abgefuckt das franchise kann ich ihnen
wollte sondern harry wollte das gestern
auf einem kanal hier nicht mitbekommen
hat beziehungsweise noch nicht mein
letztes video noch nicht angeschaut was
ich gestern hochgeladen habe harry und
francesca sind kein paar mehr
falls es nicht wusste die wurden ein
paar retour to handle aber jetzt sind es
nicht mehr weil ich gerade vor einigen
tagen break up video hochgeladen
deswegen ist es für mich heute besonders
schwer auf tortur händel zu reagieren
weil ich halt diesen fakt immer noch in
mir drin habe joeri und francesca
flirten hier gerade bei eigentlich sind
sie getrennt und haben gerade gut wir
schauen wir weiter dachte dieser nacht
schulden als wenn ich dachte es war
erlaubt habe ich überhaupt nicht gedacht
moment die uhr hat doch grün geleuchtet
bei denen heißt das dann nur dass sie
sich in diesem moment näher kommen
dürfen und auch nur irgendwie rum küssen
oder keine ahnung was weil warum haben
die dann auch auf einmal seine suite
sondern einzelne des checks ich jetzt
gar nicht so richtig nicht bei dir bin
tue ich einfach was ich für richtig
halte
ist es egal ob ich glaube den anderen
ist es nicht egal
die nacht habe ich mich so gut gefühlt
die süßen dann gibt es mich bin seit
monaten vergeblich single auf der
wunderschönen körper sehen
rugby schreien aber das wird zornig
passen aber wander und sharon versaut
war wirklich hatten sie denn jetzt
weil ich glaube ja nicht dass ich haben
kann wenn ich will
kannst du ja gerade nicht chelsea hat
dir einen korb gegeben ist so komisch zu
wissen dass harry und ron ceska gerade
so den geisteskranken beef haben ich
werde mich auf weiß konzentrieren
er ist zwar nicht unbedingt mein typ
aber seine persönlichkeit ist so cool
kirchen unbedingt besser kennenlernen
will
cross
die lampe hat wen gefunden nur das boot
könnte ein problem werden denn ich werde
schnell
[Musik]
lampen
und wasser vertragen sich auch nicht so
gut man freund hier recht seltsames zeug
und wach dann sehr aufgeregt heute
morgen sah und dachte
[Musik]
hier hören wollten dir wenigstens soweit
setzen können heute morgen sah ich die
lampe und dachte anschlag
langsam fand ich selbst die fischer hat
so ein auf und ab sie reden tag und das
ist klar weil sie so attraktiv ist und
jetzt seid ihr auseinander
er ist so komisch wie diese folge
anzuschauen zu sehen wie die beiden halb
voll cool sein bzw sich nicht war
richtig kennen was ist mir klar
denn es ist mir egal wenn es funkt
die wortspiele extra lieber was die
mädels wohl reden den klimawandel am sex
haben wollen wie dem fiesta
[Musik]
die unterhaltung in dieser show solltest
du echt mal alle bei markus lanz
einladen die leute ja gleich was mit
case angefangen obwohl ich noch nie habe
er ist der den ich keine ahnung aber
überhaupt noch interesse an
jetzt hat auch der nicht mehr bei dir
[Musik]
das darüber witze machen wenn du darüber
reden willst ja sonst nachgefragt
die beiden schenken jetzt ab und jeder
nahm liebestrunken ist der private suite
aus checken spekulieren die anderen
jungs was die zwei wohl angestellt haben
krass
ich bin echt gespannt ob die was hatten
[Applaus]
klickt euch dieses fettige
als wenn die schon zig haben
bis donnerstag und die genau die gleiche
herkommt einfach etwas peinlich sein
auto wird sie gönnt wieder nicht hayley
habe stumpf - okay das ist ja was
[Musik]
ich dachte
die uhr hat grün geleuchtet bei denen
und deswegen haben sie halt gerade kein
geld verloren du gesagt okay ich kann
[Musik]
das ist auch meine reaktion gerade ja
ich bin stolz auf dich auch ich auch auf
der einen seite bin ich irgendwie
enttäuscht weil ich halt dachte ja er
hat jetzt so voll die kranken stories
raus und die halten was und so das ist
sehr klar uns weiter und so fort aber da
war nichts
also ja die haben bisschen geld verloren
sie beim baden und berühren und
sonnencremes aber kein krasses vergeben
daumen hoch honda chip name weil er habe
nicht mit ihr geschlafen weil ich uns
beiden damit einen schlechten dienst
erwiesen
ich dachte erst dass dies nicht gemacht
hätten von wegen soja wir müssen an den
geldbetrag denken und so weiter und so
fort habe ich glaube der grund ist dass
sie sich erst näher kennenlernen wollen
und dann das ganze machen
ich freue mich am allermeisten bisher
von allen hier
das hat mir echt viel abfall
herausforderung für mich war zu sehen
wie franck wirklich ist
ich bin immer stolz ab von folge zu
folge auf alle teilnehmer dhabi hat
sie's weggesteckt gar nicht das ist das
ja
[Musik]
sind dort vielleicht den job vier alltag
london da eben in den weg für uns alle
hier
sie kennt ein tolles vorbild war
freundlich finde ich auch so etwas ja
ich mag für einen schimmer haben aber
ich lasse sie links laden wegen der
sache mit schöner blick erstmal
francesca hier
es ist ehrlich hätte wirklich nie
gedacht in einer ersten reaktion dass
das jetzt irgendwie nach meiner weiß ich
nicht 15 reaction sage oder so aber
diese serie hat einen sinn
sie hätten in tieferen sind sie versucht
den leuten die sonst nur eine
oberflächliche dinge denken beizubringen
hey achtet doch mal auf die inneren
werte und versuchte das emotionale
bindung aufzubauen und dann an die
anderen sachen ranzugehen und das lernen
die teilnehmer hier jetzt auch und schon
rauf und runter gehen mit einem guten
beispiel voran und die anderen ziehen
hoffentlich nach den mussten wir sagen
was sie fühlen sich bei mir
entschuldigen muss sich bei dir
entschuldigen
harry es ist jetzt wieder so komisch ihn
hier zu sehen und schon zu wissen was
francesca für ein video vor ein paar
tagen rausgehauen hat aber ich sehe es
ja überhaupt nicht ein dass harry hier
immer noch denkt dass von jazz kann sich
bei ihm entschuldigen muss also klar auf
der einen seite hat harry das hat mit
dem kuss vermasselt und sie halt
angeschwärzt bei der ganzen truppe auf
der anderen seite hatte francesca
allerdings auch ich werde angerufen
donnerstag
nein ich gehe es nicht mit dem saufen
ich gehe gleich kaufen wenn sich wieder
sehen lassen
ich bin heftig als sie den 86 alles
zusammen
wenn euch meine heutige reaktion auf
tour hätte gefallen hat das zeigt mir
gern mit einer bewertung unter dem video
hier meine lieben freunde schaffen gibt
50.000 likes vegas und wird mehrheit
zeigen ja weiterhin bock auf diese serie
auch wenn wir jetzt was von ceske und
harry angeht bisschen gespeichert wurden
hoffe dennoch dass euch gefallen dass
wir weiterhin bock auf die reactions
habt denn mir macht es auf jeden fall
mega viel spaß und jetzt befinden uns
auch in der endart meine lieben freunde
wenn ihr noch kein abonnent von meinem
kanal sondern klickt mal ganz schnell
obenauf den smiley drauf es ist
kostenlos und verpasst keine videos mehr
und wenn ihr meinen gestrigen reaction
auf francescas break up wieder noch
nicht gesehen habt dann klickt hier
drauf sie spielt ein bisschen und nennt
die gründe warum sie und harry nicht
mehr da